folks are still talking about what went
down at the bafta awards oh yeah first
there was William and Kate's PDA on the
red carpet and then there was bath to
opener Ariana Dubose and her rap game
that has gone viral other ladies in the
room supporting and leading all here I
presume no pressure oh time to pressure
but it's exciting
the thing Viola Davis my woman came so
we get people on their feet
instead Ariana got some very confused
looking stars in the audience during
that two minute opening number Jamie Lee
you are according to a bafta producer
Ariana co-wrote the number with her team
all these planes we needed a bigger
Throne house
figured such a slew of online memes and
criticism the Oscar winner shut down her
Twitter though today she returned to
Instagram and shared quote some moments
I loved including this shop on stage
the baftas are essentially the British
Academy Awards and the big stars showed
up and showed out Austin Butler Angela
Bassett Kate Blanchett Biola Davis and a
very playful Jamie Lee Curtis who
crashed our interview with co-star kiwi
Quan
I know I know I love her so much
and after a two-year Hiatus The Prince
and Princess of Wales made a fashionable
red carpet return before finding their
place in the front row Kate recycled the
same Alexander McQueen gown she wore to
the 2019 Baptist but the moment everyone
is talking about
yep Kate gave her husband a playful pat
on the behind as they made their way
inside so what triggered that rare Royal
PDA one lip reader claims right before
the moment Kate actually tells William
quote that man he tapped her on the
bottom another theory the couple's
flirty behavior is a way to combat
Prince Harry's claim that royal men
marry women who simply fit into the mold
meanwhile back in California Megan's rep
is going on the record with E.T slamming
a report that the sussexes are exploring
options to sue the makers of South Park
for this recent episode
in your new book when we just want to be
normal people all this attention is so
hard Megan's spokesperson calls it all
Quote nonsense totally baseless boring
reports
[Music]